Brad Paisley is gearing up for his first
Network special that's a little bit
country and a whole lot of comedy I'm
reading for the role of Nick right
I thought we'd mix it up a little bit
okay anytime you're ready you picture
things like a musical show like an
awards show or also Saturday Night Live
that's what we're going for the job Rose
guest-starred in audition for Brad the
director this camera yeah hi I'm Joe
Jonas and I'm reading for the role of
Nick Jonas today we're doing a fun skit
where we are auditioning to be the Jonas
Brothers well specifically to be me the
most important one it wasn't on paper
like that actually I just start taking
off clothes does that work for you
well hi I'm Nick I'm so strong and
talented and can't walk normal cuz have
big arms that's good thanks cut Nick
Jonas rooting for Nick Jonas hey awesome
we'll call you let you know that's good
I'm happiest when people are free to
make fun of me so internet go to town
you'll be auditioning today for the role
of my mother your mother yeah you know
so like what I do every day
yeah basically also making cameos and
Brad Paisley thinks he's special
Brett's wife Kimberly when paired up
with Tim McGraw things get a bit steamy
it says the kids come home and catch us
making out on the kitchen no it doesn't
say do it on the couch or on the bar in
the kitchen nope
and Carrie Underwood puts the pedal to
the metal huh you don't paid off this
truck right I'm gonna throw up she
scared me to death
and it's real
[Music]